what's up everybody it's warren and i
just watched the first
two episodes of the loki series coming
to disney plus
and it's really good
it uh kind of blew me away with how good
it was and
i can't say much because this isn't my
official review of that that comes
tuesday when the embargo lifts but
they allow for social media kind of
reactions at first and that's really
what this is to say
i've seen it and i loved it now this is
different than one division
and the falcon and the winter soldier
because we know loki already
he has developed already we know who the
character is
and it's everything you want from him
right whereas one division was very
different right than anything we've seen
the mcu let alone for rwanda
uh falcon the winter soldier two people
coming together to be a team for the
first time
uh kind of if you don't count civil war
but you know
it was different storyline that we
didn't really know loki we know who loki
is
and they did such a good job with this
show
i can't say much about i really really
want to so tuesday you'll have to wait
for my review
but they do a lot of really exciting
things
and loki's future in the mcu is huge and
this show is really
really really going to affect the future
of the mcu
very immediately so it's a very
important series so if you're not
interested in it
you should definitely watch it just to
know what's going to happen now again
i've only seen two episodes
i don't know how it ends but the first
episode is amazing
the second episode is really really good
as well
so loki comes out in a few days now
i'm gonna be doing my watch parties for
it it's gonna start tuesday night
uh technically wednesday morning at
12 30 a.m my time which is mountain time
so 11 30 p.m
california time pacific time so i hope
to see you all there again
i'll be joined by my buddy chris and
some other awesome people as well
so again loki series was pretty good i
think it's my favorite series so far
um it's wanda falcon the wind soldier
loki savar although i've not seen the
ending
of loki but right now it's my favorite
and i think they did
an exceptional job with it so the press
conference is tomorrow hopefully we'll
learn a little bit more
uh hopefully i get to ask some questions
and tomorrow i'll be sure to update
everybody on anything i hear
during that including on whether or not
loki is going to directly tie into
anything specific that we need to know
about the future so
loki's great you should be watching it
next week when it comes out if
you can and i'll be doing my watch
parties hope to see everybody there
thanks so much for watching
woof